sure will start to partially relax its
pandemic restrictions from Monday your
three-step plan was presented to
President Putin during a video meeting
with key ministers the country has the
world's third highest number of active
infections at the moment we have Moscow
accounting for just under two thirds of
that donal quarter breaks it down in
some more detail for us just put
together a three-stage plan in the first
stage some shops and services will begin
functioning again and people will be
able to take walks with children as well
as exercise outside again now stage 2
will be the reopening of schools and
larger shops that's that's gonna mean
that people will be able to walk with
their families on the streets in larger
groups again and by stage 3 the
government expects to reopen parks as
well as shops and restaurants with
social distancing still in place for a
period of time now we don't know how
long these stages are expected to last
or when this plan will even be
implemented but the Kremlin has already
said that they're going to need some
flexible decision-making
lizzi's sledge knee and of course life
is much more complicated than any plans
and nevertheless it's important to have
a reasonable verified algorithm of
actions for each region of the country
taking into account the opinions of
specialists we see that the situation
with the spread of coronavirus in each
of the regions is different as I've
already said in one region tough
justified preventative measures need to
be maintained or even tough freedoms and
in others it's possible to plan to ease
them if justified but that's only
possible based on the opinion of
scientists specialists and taking into
account all factors and possible risks I
emphasize again we must not run ahead of
ourselves any negligence or haste can
cause a breakdown a rollback the price
of the slightest mistake is the safety
lives and health of our peoples
therefore the responsibility for each
decision is extremely high on Thursday
Russia confirmed over 11,000 new cases
that's a record-breaking number and
after four consecutive days of increases
breaking 10,000 now Moscow is still the
coronavirus epicenter in Russia over the
past five days we've seen a steady rise
of about 5,000 cases a day in that city
although the authorities have
dramatically increased the amount of
testing their conduct
so it's possible we're just seeing an
increase in confirmed cases rather than
an increase in actual cases lately we
have increasingly multiplied a number of
tests and the number of positive cases
has increased accordingly we seed from
the dynamics but the dynamics of
positive cases doesn't indicate directly
the growth of the contagion rate it
indicates firstly the broad number of
tests and diagnosis of infected people
now whether or not the amount of cases
is actually rising this virus has no
doubt taken its toll on Russia's
leadership a number of top deputies
including the prime minister have had to
take a step back from their duties after
they were diagnosed with kovat 19 so
hopefully once this three-step plan of
Rush's is implemented the country will
be able to avoid a second wave or third
wave of the pandemic
you